Baker this has gone on long enough you
and me we're gonna throw down street
fighter 4 style end of the day well go
200 I've never played a street fighter
game in my life doesn't matter we have
got champion level Street Fighter
players gonna come in train the both of
us I got you a trainer from Capcom he is
gonna get you up to speed this is gonna
be so embarrassing knowing you're
foaming miss we sure I am terrific yep
my first tip for street fighter is that
to beat Kohler you're gonna need one of
these awesome whoa there's like eight
buttons on this thing this is gonna be
way harder than double dragon don't be
intimidated it's all gonna be all right
you're gonna take him out so what are
all the buttons here so the buttons
basically are the top row is punches the
bottom row is all kicks and you've got
standing moves and if you hold down on
the joystick you'll crouch and you can
also jump in any of three directions by
pushing up on the stick and jumping
around that way to throw a character you
got to be nearby and then you hit light
punch and light kick together there you
go to block you just hold away from the
other character so yeah so for instance
if I'm getting close to you then you
just fold away you're too far away so I
yeah so you block easily and then you
punish me on recovering I think one of
the best tips chun-li is you've already
seemed to find your way to it which is
her yet lightning leg right there you've
got it it's really a great move very
high priority even just a regular
lightning like so you can do the
Lightning leg just by basically jamming
on punch or excuse me kicks I'm
backwards on some punches there you go
you got it all right G right if i'm
gonna kick bakers ass in our match today
i'm going to need to absorb your street
fighter wisdom well if you want to be
good at street fighter you're gonna have
to make a decision I want to be Cobra
Kai or do you want to be mighty ducks I
mean you want to be strike first strike
are no mercy sir or do you want to take
the fall act hurt be indignant I don't
understand what that means can you just
teach me about Street Fighter please we
can do that okay thank you in street
fighter 4 there are three different
types of special moves that you can do
you have your normal special move
like ahead you can or a tiger top there
well you do a basic command and one
punch button you have your super meter
now at the bottom you can see it
flashing super there the blue one right
yellow one and when that's full you can
do a super move when takes away the blue
bar that's when you do you know made two
commands in a row and a punch that's a
more powerful attack right but then the
big red thing on fire the glowing orb
yes that's your ultra bar that looks
awesome the ultra part this is ultra
vires earned when you get hurt so it's
kind of like the revenge tactic and when
you get an ultra then you can unleash a
really powerful attack by doing the
command and all three punches or kicks
so in reuse taste as the shinku a token
which is a very mighty to focus attack
you hold the two mediums together and
you'll see that you charge up and tack
and then you only so go ahead and
getting at that okay and as you charge
it up it becomes there's three separate
stages for it and at its height at the
you know at that last stage we add the
last stage of its charge it is
completely unblockable oh now you can do
is then you know they're pretty much
open to attack so okay so you can do a
focus attack and then kind of dash it
any dash follow it up with something
that followed up hey everybody Rose here
from sham wow it's a chamois it's a
scarf it's an ultra shamwows for the car
it's for the full it's pretty Conda it
for Blanca why are you gonna spend full
bars on a super you're gonna get the st.
damage anyway here's a bow rod we spilt
on the copy without applying any
question let's ticket to send your life
bar right there following me camera guy
ShamWow you're gonna say wow every time
I don't know man what do you got I got
20 on Cole what's good you you should be
betting on your own guy I got 20 on Cole
it yeah I'll I'll throw on down smoke
Sekot vs. show me no contest Oh Baker
knows how to block oh oh oh no oh
my god Baker's actually going to win
round one to you Baker round one to you
I'm learning all the baloney the Capcom
taught you know about your lightning
kicks round to me what up now ahhh that
was close you know what Baker you
actually did a really good job well what
have we learned today Baker we've
learned that you've gotta get these
things aligned or something before you
play it no I think we've learned today
is that it's not the size of your
joystick it's what you do with it that
counts
so um your name is Seth true and the
final boss of street fighter 4 also
named Seth noticed also true yeah so
like if I worked at capcom i could be a
street fighter four character right no
really no not at all no I but ok I mean
I just want to show you i worked up this
concept art and I really think no don't
ever show me that again sorry